thanks very much for coming in and
sitting down with me purnima we're
building a new app here for a company
we're looking specifically at the to do
and calendar management space and so
based on the float that I've laid out
here I'd like to talk to you about a
couple of different things that we're
seeing with it so obviously over here we
have a very clear screen for creating
and editing new events but I'm kind of
curious to understand initially coming
from the home screen or the the day at a
glance screen do you see an easy and
clear way to create new entries yes that
using the floating action button perfect
so the floating action button is a
pattern that we've established across
our application here and so we have fabs
in a couple of different places fab
placement has been a thing that we've
dealt with in the past and so I'm kind
of curious to understand you know on
these two screens we've got fabs up near
the the hero section of the page but
over here we've got to fab down at the
bottom of the page does the the location
of fab changing does that cause any
issues for you or are you comfortable
with that um I personally like it with
the hero by the hero banner I don't know
why because I'm able to see all the
events down below so and then you know
looking over that and then I have to go
over and search for the floating action
button so which is why I feel you know
it's actually kind of nice when it's
with the hero banner yeah you know even
with us such a strong affordance
associated with the hero banner you know
we can still get at it here on this
screen as well but there is no hero
element to associate with and so we
still end up having to roll with it at
the bottom of the screen here one of the
things too is that one of our concerns
is that with a fab at this size right
that potentially could obscure some of
the information that we're looking at
here now in this case if we're just
looking at that it's just avatars of the
people but as you're scrolling through
the list there could be more valuable
bits of information do you feel that
that would be a real strong problem for
our users or they would be able to work
around that with scrolling I think they
would be able to work around that
although you know it does look a little
you know like blocking some of
content like that might happen but i
think you know once you get a hang of it
and once you're comfortable with the app
i think eventually like users will get a
hang of it okay interesting so i have
one big question given that this is a
sort of a to do in an event management
system do you see a clear way to
actually say i'm done with this
particular event um do you mean to say
bye just crossing it off clearing it
from the list mm-hmm and just marking so
I think it's these check buttons oh very
cool okay so you picked up that
affordance quite quickly whereas other
participants we've had come through our
study have maybe struggle with that just
a little bit why do you feel that that
affordance jumped out for you so quickly
I mean you picked up on it really I
think um it's sort of like the
distinguishing factor between one of
them were was checked and the other was
not Jesse so I figured okay this event
is probably over it's done so you know
you move on and check the rest of them
yeah you know it's interesting though
that in this case the affordance is just
a great dog yeah um so if you were to
see three gray dots here and perhaps not
the checkbox do you think that that
would stand out as much for you um I
think that would be a little confusing
do you know yeah what does this button
do maybe I would be curious to try it
out and see what happens that
interesting okay so you're willing to be
a little bit forgiving with the
application try something stuff to learn
what the pattern is interesting um one
other big question that's come up in
previous feedback is that we can only
manage those events from this particular
screen do you feel strongly that we
would want to be able to manage them
from something like the home screen the
home screen is much more of an at a
glance screen and so we did not strongly
associate event management there do you
still feel that that's valuable do we
need to go that direction yeah I think
it definitely will be convenient since
its listing out the details off the
event you know to be able to check it
off or with respect to are you talking
with respect to details that
particularly need to
be in the home screen or just about like
having to manipulate edit events it's
really slowly just about manipulating
riding events yeah I think um we could
add something like just wiping the event
and you know giving the user more
options on you know what they can
actually do like what editing options
they actually get Wow doing that so if
we were to add some sort of Swiper or
some other gesture support to one of
these screens what would your
expectation be that that gesture would
do if we were to for instance swipe
across one of these things from most of
the apps that I've used probably have a
delete as well as maybe more that would
take you to a list of functionality like
it did you know would you would you want
to reveal like a hidden panel behind
that thing or go with something that's a
little more like Google's inbox where
it's just task completion um I think I
would want um more of a panel I see okay
options more option you'd want to see
more options yeah interesting um if we
did support something like just a
gesture to mark a task complete I'm not
a revealed panel would you want that
that particular entry to disappear would
you want it to remain on the screen what
would be a clear indication aside from
just a blue checkbox that this event is
done um I I think that any event that's
done does not like need to appear on the
home screen so I'm just thinking why it
would have to be on the home screen once
the event is over so I would only have
maybe like checking it off would mean
it's going to disappear from the list
interesting would you have that same
expectation of the daily at a glance
screen would you want to see things that
have been completed there because it
sounds to me like in your heads up in
kind of our landing page you don't want
to see that would but you do want to see
in here yeah in the daily you know
calendar like daily event list I
want to see all the events that have
been completed and you know events that
are coming up yeah you know I think in
previous feedback we got an indicator
that we would want to see that stuff in
case we made a mistake yeah we
accidentally swipe something that we can
tend to okay one last question for you
and then I'll let you get back to your
work so the one thing that we haven't
talked a whole lot about is how we
delete events right it's one thing to
say that an event is done but I've just
made a mistaken of created one where
would you expect to see delete come out
in this UI um so I think delete would be
when you swipe the event you know just
have a regret delete so you see there so
you'd want to reveal a panel like
gorilla panel that says delete and other
options uh-huh potentially but if we
were to create like an edit you I like
this where when you tap on one of these
things you come to an edit you I you
would see the title of the text that
people would you expect to see a delete
button on that edit screen as well um i
would expect something like a cancel to
say that oh I could I clicked on the new
event button by mistake so I don't want
to create a new event so of course I
know that the up navigation and you know
takes you one page back but I think a
cancel button to just like go back to
the home screen would be introduced for
you want a stronger affordance there
okay great well I really appreciate all
the feedback that you've given us this
is really helpful in setting the
direction of the tone for the next
iteration thanks for coming on hoping
yeah